(audience clapping)
- [Kelly] So, there were rumors though,
that you were going to
join your Melrose co-star.
so at least you (indistinct)
on Real Housewives.
Is that true?
- You know.
- Would you do that?
- I'm so not interesting. No.
(Kelly laughing)
- I mean no.
- I thought you were going
to say "Not interested"
You said I'm not interesting.
- Well, I'm not interesting, enough.
And I don't drink and that and I,
I, I, you know, I, I'm like, no,
that's not quite what I want to do.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But thank you.
- But, yeah.
- [Kelly] Just to be on
camera all the time like that.
And I feel like they want, like,
producers sometimes want
you to create drama.
And I'm just like.
- [Heather] I think so.
- Aghh! That's not my vibe.
- And I think like, oh. I'm
just going to lay in bed.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
But I don't find myself
very interesting that
even like on tour, like I play Scrabble
and read books after shows.
- Very good.
- I'm not cool.
- Yeah. No.
- I'm like the opposite of cool.
- Right.
- But whatever. Unless you
think that's cool then.
- I think that's cool.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
Well, let's talk about your new movie.
So it's called "Don't
sweat the small stuff",
which I love that.
- [Heather] A Kristine Carlson story.
- [Kelly] So what's, what's it about,
other than not sweating the small stuff.
- Okay, there was a book in the nineties.
You weren't born.
- What!I'm born in 82. What?
- Well.
- I'm 39.
- Or whatever. Anyway.
- I am a fine wine.
- You are a fine wine.
(audience cheering)
- So, what's it about?
- So, it was this very
hugely popular book.
And her husband, Richard and her, she,
they started doing the books together
and it became this whole thing
and people kind of forgot about it,
but he passed away at 45.
- That's young.
- Very young, unexpected.
And so it's really about
her and her daughters
trying to make the
journey through, you know,
death of the father and
the love of her life.
They were very, very spiritual
and very together on
everything at entire level.
- [Kelly] That's sad.
- Yeah. It was really
awful if you read the book,
you'll oh, if you need a
good cry, read the book.
- I love a good cry.
- I love it.
- I'm in.
- Sometimes like get it out.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Or get in the shower.
- Whatever.
- [Kelly] Oh my God! A shower cry.
- I love a shower cry.
Feels good, and it's like,
nothing's really happening, you know?
It's like, yeah. The water.
- My publicist calls it a baptism.
- [Kelly] Baptism?
- Another baptism.
- [Kelly] Yes!
- Isn't that good?
- [Kelly] Yeah, you're in the water.
- Right. There you go. So anyway, it's,
it's her journey through
the process of grieving
or not grieving and whatever she did.
And she came out on the
other side of it as her.
Yeah. Ah!
And with her two daughters, stronger woman
and really a person who helps other people
process through, through
death, through a divorce,
through, you know, job
loss, anything like that.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Heather] She's really wonderful.
- And just grieve, in general. Yeah.
- [Heather] Yeah.
- Any kind of, any kind of grief.
- [Heather] Any kind of grief.
- I love that.
- [Heather] Yeah.
(audience clapping)
- That's gonna be awesome.
- [Heather] Yeah.
- I want to watch and
read it. I love reading.
- Yeah. Yeah. The book's amazing.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Okay. I'll do both.